Beauty Brands are talking a lot more
about sustainability and the environment
and it makes sense climate change is a
huge problem and most of us don't want
to make things worse well maybe not him
but Beauty marketing is full of false
promises and meaningless buzzwords
what's actually better for the
environment and what is feel good fluff
well most of it is fluff I'm Michelle
chem PhD cosmetic chemist and marketing
connoisseur I'm here with Jen and other
kids medic chemist and science
Communicator who specializes in
sustainability we're going to break down
some of the most common myths that
brands use to pretend they're greener
than they are so you can see through the
marketing more easily and make informed
decisions about what to buy but it's not
all doom and gloom we will also go
through things we can do to actually be
more sustainable so stick around till
the end let's start with the idea that
natural ingredients are better for the
environment than synthetic ones when you
finish using them and they drift off
into the environment this Smith shows up
a lot with sunscreens some places are
Banning chemical sunscreens because of
the idea that they harm coral reefs but
this isn't based on good evidence I've
talked about it before instead these
places are promoting mineral sunscreens
mostly with zinc oxide based on on this
assumption that it is natural and
therefore won't harm Coral or any other
Wildlife this is not true when zinc
oxide sunscreen gets washed off your
body it doesn't necessarily end up
someplace that naturally has zinc oxide
and even if it does it can raise the
concentration there compared to before
and how harmful something is depends on
how much there is so extra zinc oxide
can be a problem there are actually a
lot of studies showing that zinc oxide
is toxic to Coral and other aquatic
organisms for example these data tables
come from a 2022 National academies
report on the environmental impacts of
sunscreen each of these rows is an
example of a harmful effect that zinc
oxide has been found to have there's
also this diagram that compares the
toxicity of different chemical and
physical sunscreen ingredients each
black dot is an amount that caused a
Toxic effect in a study the lower a DOT
is on this graph the less you need of
that ingredient to have the harmful
effect in other words the more potently
harmful it is you can see that both zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide all the
natural sunscreen can start causing harm
at lower concentrations than some
unnatural chemical sunscreens as the
report says these two categories of UV
filters completely overlap with respect
to acute toxicity and this is still the
case with non-nano zinc oxide Nano
refers to smaller particles that tend to
be used in sunscreens because they
protect against UV batter and they look
a bit less clown-like in a lot of
sunscreen marketing you'll see this idea
that if you use larger non-nanoparticles
it will be completely safe but zinc
oxide dissolves in water which means
larger particles get smaller like And
subscribe for more mind-blowing facts
like these plus those dissolved zinc
ions can also be harmful zinc is a
micronutrient that living organisms need
but it is also a heavy metal it's toxic
if there's too much that's why if you
look up the safety data sheet for zinc
oxide you'll see this symbol featuring a
dead fish it's surrounded by warnings
about how it's very toxic to Aquatic
Life zinc oxide even when a non-nano
form has been reckon as potentially
toxic for a really long time near the
chemical nor physical sunscreen seemed
to be a big issue for coral reefs based
on the relevant evidence so far the
amounts near race are too low to be
having that much of an impact especially
in light of other stresses like Rising
temperatures research is still ongoing
also for other aquatic organisms but
it's pretty clear that zinc oxide isn't
a completely safe alternative and this
goes for pretty much any natural
ingredient just because it's natural
doesn't mean it's safe which you
hopefully already know because nature is
always trying to kill us also the zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide and
sunscreens isn't really natural most of
the time it's usually man-made that's
because if you just take them from
nature they're often contaminated with
very natural toxic heavy metals like
lead this is also the reason why natural
iron oxides which are the skin colored
pigments and Foundation aren't allowed
in cosmetics in the US they have to be
synthetic when we talk about the
environmental impacts of different
ingredients in our products we usually
focus on where where the ingredients go
after we finish using them this is going
to be a recurring theme what we can see
and control is usually what we think
about where the product goes after we've
used it we can see it going down the
drain and what we do with the empty
packaging but this is only one part of
environmental impact there's also
getting those ingredients in the first
place and a lot of people assume that
natural ingredients are more
environmentally friendly to produce than
synthetic ones again this is not true
and this production part is a really big
factor when it comes to the overall
environmental impact the more holistic
way of thinking about impact is to look
at the whole life cycle of the product
this is the life cycle most of the time
we focus on this part which is disposal
and recycling also called end of life
but there's a lot that happens before
the product actually gets to you and all
of these have environmental impacts the
raw materials get processed and turn
into ingredients which then get turned
into your product the same steps happen
to make the packaging your product then
gets shipped a bunch of time times
there's also a bunch of shipping in that
first part then it ends up at your house
you use it which is another big part of
the impact for example with water use
and then there's the disposal in
recycling we've already talked about the
disposal of ingredients and how natural
isn't always better but natural also
isn't automatically better when it comes
to production when we hear natural it
kind of sounds like someone wanders
through a forest and picks leaves off
trees and mashes them to make your
products while birds chirp and deer
dance it just sounds more sustainable
but that is pretty far from reality
there are lots of natural ingredients
that have huge environmental costs to
produce for example essential oils it
can take hundreds to thousands of
kilograms of plant material to get a
single kilogram of essential oil and
many essential oils are mostly sourced
from plants growing in the wild or at
least the wild versions are more
valuable one example that Jens talked
about before is Indian Sandalwood
Sandalwood is the most you can
economically important tree globally the
value hinges on aromatic chemical
composition namely High sandal content
sandalo content is concentrated as trees
get older harvesting generally happens
when the trees aren't 30 years old this
coupled with growing demand plus
widespread fungal infection has driven
the species to endangerment adulteration
smuggling and illicit trade remain major
challenges another example is licorice
extract and skincare is usually wild
harvested licorice that's used because
it has a high concentration of the
Active Components wild licorice has been
uncontrollably over harvested to the
point that there is now more licorice
being sold in the market than there is
being produced licorice helps soils with
sand management and therefore over
exploitation of wild licorice in the
Sandy regions it typically grows
directly contributes to desertification
for both sandalwood and licorice the
obvious solution is to limit wild
harvesting which is harder than it
sounds and switch to fond Verge which is
a bit less natural and usually lower
quality there's been efforts to increase
the quality of the farm versions but
that is also harder than it sounds and
even though in these cases farming is
more sustainable than wild harvesting it
is still not great for the environment
agriculture has a huge impact on the
environment according to the 2019 ipbes
report agricultural expansion into
intact ecosystems was the greatest
threat to biodiversity loss agriculture
is also a significant contributor to
greenhouse gas emissions and we don't
just find cosmetic ingredients the land
and resources could have been used to
produce food instead food security is a
really big issue right now we have an
immense Global challenge of figuring out
how to feed our growing population with
the limited resources we have while also
reducing our impacts from my perspective
it's hugely problematic to divert
agrispace away from food towards
production of things like Cosmetics or
Aroma chemicals especially if there's a
less impactful way of production already
available and these less impact
s ultimately is complex and it depends
many natural materials in cosmetics are
byproducts of food agriculture or even
biodiesel production albeit this in
itself is problematic for similar
reasons some essential oils are produced
via byproducts and can be considered as
upcycled for these the continued use of
natural materials makes sense and a lot
of the time ingredients made from
byproducts are also cheaper this links
to another really annoying marketing
Trope a lot of clean natural Brands like
to brag about how precious and rare the
ingredients are how many rose petals are
in each bottle how long it took to grow
and they shame other ingredients which
are usually synthetic for being cheap
and then at the same time they claim to
be more sustainable this makes zero
sense if more resources went into making
a product that is not more sustainable
cheaper ingredients that are made from
Salvage waste materials are usually a
more sustainable option even though
there is this sort of snobbery against
them turning waste into something useful
and valuable is a good thing from an
environmental perspective and on this
theme of making the most out of limited
resources here is the next myth
organically farmed ingredients are more
environmentally friendly than
conventionally farmed ones most people
think organic means more environmentally
friendly because that is what organic
farming organizations say that their
goal is it's in all four of their
founding principles but if you look at
the actual rules that farmers need to
follow to be certified organic you'll
see that they aren't actually based on
scientific evidence it's mostly just
based on this idea of naturalness in
general synthetic substances like
pesticides and fertilizers are
prohibited and non-synthetic substances
are allowed but like we've discussed
natural isn't necessarily better for the
environment and this applies to
pesticides too more and more Studies
have found that organic farming can
actually end up with greater
environmental impacts in a lot of areas
this 2017 meta-analysis compared a bunch
of studies looking at the environmental
impacts of conventional versus organic
farming they looked at producing 90
different food Foods the higher a DOT is
on this graph the worse organic farming
is compared to Conventional farming
first off you can see that a lot of it
depends on the type of food the
different colored dots represent
different categories of food and they're
at different heights there is also a lot
of variation for the specific farms in
different countries for a lot of the
data sets there's a really long line
which means that there is a huge range
involved so it isn't like organic is
always better or conventional is always
better but there are some categories of
environmental impact where organic is
generally worse and since then there's
been more analyzes where scientists have
started taking land use into account
when looking at the greenhouse gas
impact which this analysis didn't do
organic farming tends to be less
efficient more land is needed to produce
the same amount of a crop and if you're
using that land for farming you will
generally need to clear trees having
less trees means that you have less
carbon dioxide being absorbed so there
is essentially going to be an
opportunity cost and if you factor that
greater land you Houston it turns out
that organic farming usually produces a
lot more greenhouse gases one analysis
found that in Sweden organic peas would
have a 50 greater greenhouse gas impact
than conventionally farmed peas for
winter wheat the difference was 70
percent in order to meet our growing
demand in light of the environmental
limitations and impacts associated with
agriculture we need to figure out how to
produce more ingredients with the same
or even less impact despite that there
is a market push to tell us that organic
is sustainable there are some serious
limitations of organic agriculture
especially pertaining to its efficiency
this isn't to say that organic
agriculture is unsustainable Full Stop
in some regions it may make sense in the
same way that in other regions
conventional agriculture or even genetic
engineering may be the better option
ultimately there are no panaceas when it
comes to sustainability in agriculture
whether organical conventional methods
are better changes a lot depending on
the context and what impact you're
looking at not even just with the
specific crops and environmental impacts
but also things like pesticide exposure
for farmers and consumer prices even if
we look at biodiversity which is one of
the more widely accepted advantages of
organic farming it turns out that if you
take that extra land use into account on
average it breaks even the obvious
solution would be to use whatever
methods have lower environmental impacts
in a particular situation whether
they're organic or not but organic
doesn't allow that it just limits the
options that farmers have based on this
misconception that natural is better in
some situations like the cereal crops
and bird biodiversity it's better to
produce the same amount of food in a
smaller area using conventional farming
and leave a strip of un farm land than
it is to use a larger area for organic
farming but that would not be allowed
under organic rules and there are more
examples now of more environmentally
sustainable farming practices that kind
of just ignore organic and we haven't
actually dealt with that mold thing yet
natural products tend to have shorter
shelf lives and go off faster than
products with more synthetic components
a lot of synthetic ingredients were
originally designed as improvements on
naturally occurring chemicals it isn't
always the case but there is a reason
why no one is that surprised where
natural products have texture or color
changes or start growing mold and if you
have to throw out half the product that
means that the stuff that you used with
that waste taken into account will be a
lot more resource intensive to produce
speaking of Natural Things decomposing
our next myth making synthetic
ingredients from petrochemicals is worse
for the environment there's this idea
that synthetic ingredients made from
petroleum are bad for the environment
because petroleum is a fossil fuel yes
fossil fuels are bad for the environment
extracting petroleum through processes
like fracking can be really destructive
and there's also all the carbon dioxide
that gets released when they're burned
as a fuel to release energy which is the
main driver of climate change but there
are some big differences between
petroleum as a fuel and ingredients that
are made from petroleum there is no
petroleum sourcing with the intent of
making cosmetic ingredients the
petrochemicals that are used are all
waste products from the petroleum sector
societally we want to move away from our
Reliance of fossil fuels but until the
world does and while the world is fueled
by them the byproducts that the
Cosmetics use will be there in the
future this may not be the case but this
is the current reality and making
natural ingredients also uses up fossil
fuels chilling making fertilizer and
pesticides moving water for irrigation
harvesting transporting plant materials
processing purification all of this uses
energy which usually comes from fossil
fuels and this time the fossil fuels are
purposely dug up and burned as fuels to
get out energy and that burning is the
part that releases carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere if petroleum jelly isn't
burnt then that carbon stays sequestered
in the petroleum jelly and it won't
directly contribute to climate change
again it depends on the specific
situation synthetic isn't always less
impactful than natural making synthetic
ingredients process assessing and
purifying them also uses energy and
again this mostly comes from burning
fossil fuels and again some natural
ingredients are also made from waste
materials from other processes which
means Energy savings and less carbon
dioxide so it all comes back to looking
at the data for each individual
ingredient which means life cycle
analyzes a few examples an LCA from
semrise where they show that their
synthetically produced Menthol produced
8 kilograms of CO2 per kilogram Menthol
first 50 to 100 for its natural
counterpart in contrast we conducted
genomatica's brontide butylene glycol
where they halft their CO2 emissions
with the use of plant-based starting
points via biotechnology instead of the
traditional production from fossil fuels
then again since they use a genetically
modified biocatalyst in this process
many consumers and ecocertifiers still
view this as unsustainable there is no
blanket rule about natural always being
more sustainable when we're considering
whether or not natural materials are
more or less impactful we should be
asking ourselves are we using prime
agricultural land to produce them or are
they coming from waste or byproducts
from crops that we're already using
anyway in other sectors this also means
there's no blanket rule about what
benefits the fossil fuel industry more
buying synthetic ingredients made from
petrochemicals versus buying natural
ingredients that use a lot of fossil
fuels to produce and speaking of myths
about petrochemicals we need to talk
about packaging the idea that plastic is
always worse for the environment than
other types of packaging is everywhere
not just in cosmetics and it is again a
massive oversimplification like I
mentioned before a lot of this is
because we tend to focus on just that
end of Life part when we choose products
because we have to personally deal with
it does the bottle go into the bin or
can it be reused or recycled does it
degrade and just like before end of life
is just one part of environmental impact
if we stop using all plastic and use
more eco-friendly Alternatives instead
like glass paper and aluminum we would
need on average 3.6 times the material
2.2 times the energy and there would be
an average increase of about 2.7 times
the carbon dioxide emissions this makes
a lot of sense if we look at each part
of the life cycle plastic isn't
universally the worst option for any
part for example with production plastic
is produced via byproducts of the
petroleum sector contrast that to paper
where there's a lot of processing from
wood and then glass and aluminum they
can come from recycled sources but there
is a lot of heat involved that increases
the impact one of the things we need to
remember is why plastic packaging became
so widespread in the first place it is
really good at protecting the stuff
inside it to transportation for example
with glass versus plastic plastic is
lightweight for its strength and
therefore the transportation CO2
emissions tend to be less there's also
the matter of glass breakage in similar
4 aluminum aluminum is heavier it dents
easily and people don't want to buy it
then even for end of life mono material
plastic can be recycled about 40 times
in some companies to strive for Eco
options are switching to partly paper
packaging which ends up needing a
plastic layer since paper doesn't stand
up to for example water and then as a
result they end up using multi-layered
materials that are harder to recycle and
ends up being worse ultimately here the
best packaging option in terms of the
environmental impact is a case-by-case
basis with the best option varying
greatly from Individual formulations and
users for example what are the users
habits what kind of recycling
infrastructure do they have available is
your bottle return program something
that they can viably access blanket
statements at plastic equals bad are
both from my perspective unhelpful and
potentially harmful at the end of the
day there is no Silver Bullet for
sustainable packaging and every option
has its pros and cons so hopefully from
all of this it's clear that
sustainability is complicated and
straightforward blanket rules just don't
work we can't just always choose natural
organic products or choose glass over
plastic and expect that we are making
the better choice so what can we
actually do to be more sustainable I
think the most obvious thing to do is to
just consume less buying something is
almost always going to be less
sustainable than not buying something
regardless of whether it's eco-friendly
per capita consumerism is the most
environmentally destructive thing we do
societally the overwhelming evidence
shows that the negative impacts
associated with over consumption vastly
outweigh any of the positives associated
with green Innovation so it's important
to consider if you really need to buy
some
like you'll see giving the planet just
by buying their product when in reality
it is probably going to have a net
negative impact and this is filtering
into regulation for example in the UK
they've already said that labels like
green sustainable and eco-friendly could
be considered deceptive unless a
business can prove that as a whole there
is a positive environmental impact to
using the product which is pretty
unlikely there's a push towards green
consumerism which is ultimately at odds
with sustainability as it paradoxically
increases consumption which increases
impact also there is a market
incentivization for green consumers are
willing to pay more for products they
perceive to be green and there is also a
rapidly growing market for impact or ESG
investment where investors want to
invest in companies they again perceive
to be socially or ecologically Superior
given how how complicated and context
dependent sustainability is I think it
is also really important to ask
questions if a brand says that their
product is sustainable ask them for
evidence because there's so much
complexity we can't work out what's
going on without Brands providing some
level of transparency we don't know how
the butylene glycol in their product was
made we don't know whether their
production plant uses renewable energy
companies pursuing sustainable
development must have access to as much
relevant information as they can in
order to make the best possible decision
to get this information they must
measure and record data in terms of
their specific goals environmental
accounting is the backbone of
sustainable development because you
can't be accountable unless you're
actually accounting for things life
cycle assessments can be seen as the
most important tool for understanding a
product's impact for example actually
calculating specific environmental
impacts of every single ingredient and
how much is going into the product or
how things are being transported Etc
room a lot of the time the clean
movement just bases their ideologies on
assumptions like assuming that natural
is always safer if we want to move to
reduce our impacts we need
substantiation and we need the specific
measures to be relevant and standardized
so you can actually make comparisons
between companies most of the current
popular Eco standards certifiers and the
labels you see around don't do this very
well and as a consequence they may
actually be resulting in more
greenwashing rather than true
sustainability progress despite how
they're positioning themselves it's also
important as consumers to be informed
about what things are actually more
sustainable the beauty industry responds
to Consumer demand if we push for the
wrong thing like non-evidence space
eco-certifications or less plastic or
more natural ingredients regardless of
what the environmental impacts actually
are brands are going to deliver it so we
could be contributing to making
everything worse like we saw with clean
Beauty people pushing for paraben free
product announcement that Brands started
using less effective and more irritating
allergenic preservatives that led to
more skin reactions maybe an allergy
epidemic and products that go off faster
so it's important not to go for easy
answers and make sure you're sharing the
correct information and if you see
people in brand spreading myths it's
important to counteract that and tell
people where they can find better
information a problem we're increasingly
seeing is misplaced conservation where
misinformation and polarization can
actually work together against
sustainable development for example by
leading to a misallocation of resources
into efforts that fundamentally don't
make sense sometimes making the issues
that they're trying to address worse a
second way sustainability misinformation
is working against sustainable
development is via green nudging when
ineffective but perhaps easier policy
comes before the effective but harder
policy the effect of policy is less
likely to be successful if the effective
policy comes first the chances of
success are much greater one example
here could be carbon pricing well
supported by the scientific evidence to
be an effective strategy for climate
change mitigation having policy that
focuses on things like carbon
footprinting which is widely debated as
an effective strategy come before as
we're currently doing when we finally
get to the carbon pricing it's going to
be an increasingly uphill battle the
order of policy in environmental action
in general matters therefore relying on
the best available evidence is crucially
important as we pursue sustainable
development one final thing I want to
add is that if we want to make
significant strides towards
sustainability what we really need are
science-based policy changes consumer
scapegoating and corporate
sustainability aren't working we've seen
this with carbon pricing which as
mentioned is one of the more
well-supported policies for addressing
climate change but instead of focusing
on implementing it effectively there's a
lot of blame on consumers and a lot of
focus on things like carbon footprinting
which has incentivized a pretty
problematic market for carbon offsets
which is yet another whole complex topic
I won't get into here sustainability is
obviously a huge topic so we only
covered a tiny fraction of it here let
us know what other questions about
sustainability you have if you want to
find out more about these topics I've
linked some of Jen's posts and podcasts
which are amazing definitely check those
out we've also started Beauty Cyclone
which will hopefully spread more
accurate Beauty science information
check us out as well